hi everyone
this is professor m.science and today i
want to talk about the
time energy uncertainty principle in
another one of our videos on rigorous
quantum mechanics
uncertainty principles are a rather
famous aspect of quantum mechanics
you'll most likely have heard about the
position momentum
uncertainty principle another
uncertainty principle that many of you
may have heard about is the topic of
today's video
the time energy uncertainty principle
interestingly
the time energy uncertainty principle is
fundamentally different
from all other uncertainty principles
let's take the position and momentum
example again
both of them are observables represented
by operators in quantum mechanics and it
is true in general
there is an uncertainty principle
between any two observables
a and b but time is not an observable in
quantum mechanics
it's a parameter this already suggests
that the time
energy uncertainty principle is
fundamentally different
today we'll explore what we actually
mean by the time
energy uncertainty principle let's go to
understand what we mean by the time
energy uncertainty relation we need to
start by setting the scene
we consider the following scenario first
we have the hamiltonian age of the
system which is the observable
associated with the total
energy today we'll focus on time
independent hamiltonians remember from
the video on the
your equation that this means that we
have what is called the conservative
system
and second we have another observable a
we'll also assume that this observable
does not explicitly depend on time
and remember that this means that the
derivative of a with respect to time
vanishes we next define the root mean
square deviations of these two
observables
you can find the background on root mean
square deviations in the corresponding
video link in the description
but as a summary we write the root mean
square deviation of an operator like the
hamiltonian
as delta h and it is equal to the square
root
of the expectation value of h squared
minus the expectation value of h all
squared
we can also write it in another way
which is the square root of the
expectation value of an operator sigma
squared where sigma is defined like this
so that it measures the spread of the
operator with respect to its expectation
value
we can of course also define the root
mean square deviation of a
using the same set of expressions like
this
or like this where sigma a has an
analogous definition
from the videos on the heisenberg
uncertainty principle which you can also
find linked in the description
we know that the root mean square
deviation of a
multiplied by the root mean square
deviation of h
is larger than or equal to one half
times the absolute value
of the expectation value of the
commutator between a
and h this is what we call the
uncertainty principle
this uncertainty relation will be the
starting point for our discussion today
but before we go into it let's briefly
remember what it means
we'll go over its meaning rather quickly
so if you want a more detailed
discussion you should check out the
videos on the heisenberg concert in the
principle that you can find linked in
the description
we need to consider three ingredients
the first
is the eigenvalue equation of the
hamiltonian
where as usual these are the eigenvalues
and these are the eigenstates
the second ingredient is the eigenvalue
equation of the operator
a where again these are the eigenvalues
and these the eigenstates and the third
ingredient
is the state psi of the system
the next step is to represent the state
psi of the system in the two bases
spanned by the eigenstates of h and of a
in terms of the eigenstates of h we have
this expansion
where the expansion coefficients are
given as usual by this bracket
we can also expand the same state psi in
the basis of eigenstates of a
where now the expansion coefficients are
given by the corresponding bracket
to qualitatively understand the
heisenberg uncertainty principle we can
use a pictorial representation
of these expansions let's draw a set of
axes
and we place the energy eigenvalues on
the horizontal axis
and the expansion coefficient squared on
the vertical axis
we can then draw the representation of
this expansion like this
with the height of these lines
indicating the contribution of each
energy eigenstate to the expansion of
psi
in the energy basis
so how can we understand this in this
particular example the distribution pigs
around this value
so the eigenstate in this region make a
big contribution to the expansion of psi
and the eigenstates away from this peak
make a very small contribution to psi
the root mean square deviation of h then
simply measures the width
of this distribution this means that
small
values of delta h indicate that only a
few states are present in the expansion
of psi
whereas a larger delta h would indicate
that many states contribute
if we now look at the heisemberg
uncertainty principle up here
then it's giving us a relation between
the spread of the distributions when we
write the state psi
in the two bases associated with h and
with a
in particular if a and h do not commute
then the product of the two root mean
square deviations has to be larger than
some positive lower bounds
this means that if we draw the
corresponding pictorial representation
associated with observable a
then as in our example the delta h is
rather small
then the delta a must be rather large
and this is to ensure that their product
obeys the uncertainty principle this
means that the distribution must look
something like this
with a rather large delta a
just to be absolutely clear these two
distributions are a pictorial
representation of the same
state psi up here they're simply showing
the same state
in two different bases and what the
heisenberg uncertainty principle gives
us is a relation
between these two distributions
now this was a quick summary but you
should be familiar with this if you've
seen our videos on the heisenberg
uncertainty principle
if you haven't then i would encourage
you to check them out before you
continue
because our discussion today will build
on this and the heisenberg uncertainty
principle
isn't always explained very well so it
is important to make sure that we have a
clear understanding
before we proceed what we'll see today
is that the time
energy uncertainty relation is quite
different to this general uncertainty
relation
but at the same time we'll see it's not
completely unrelated to it
the next step requires a result that we
obtained in the video on the air infest
theorem
we can write the time derivative of the
expectation value of a general
observable q
as 1 over i h-bar times the expectation
value of the commutator of
q with the hamiltonian plus the
expectation value of the time derivative
of q in our case
we're working with an observable a and
in fact we can simply write it down as
equal to the first term
because in our setup in the first slide
we discussed that we're working with
observables that do not explicitly
depend on time
we can now isolate the expectation value
of the commutator
which is equal to ihbar multiplied by
the time derivative of the expectation
value
the next step is to use this latest
expression for the expectation value of
the commutator
and insert it into the uncertainty
principle up here
doing so we get that delta a delta h
is larger than or equal to this
we can simplify the right hand side to h
bar over 2
times the absolute value of the time
derivative
and finally we can rearrange the
expression to end up with the term
featuring the observable a
then delta h or larger than or equal to
one half times h bar
this term here has dimensions of time so
we can define a new quantity delta t
as equal to it to conform to the usual
notation used we're also going to give a
different label to delta h
and we'll call it delta e now this is
abusing notation somewhat because we've
so far been using delta of an operator
for example
delta h hat to characterize the root
mean square deviation
but to conform to the usual notation i'm
now replacing the delta of the operator
h
by delta e but we must not forget what
this really means
and we're now ready to write down the
time energy
uncertainty relation delta t
times delta e is larger than or equal to
one-half h-bar
superficially it looks very similar to
other uncertainty relations we're
familiar with
for example the position momentum
uncertainty relation is given by delta x
delta p larger than or equal to one half
h bar
however these two relations are
fundamentally very different
in quantum mechanics both position
and momentum are observables represented
by operators
energy is also an observable and as we
discussed a moment ago
here we're using the conventional
notation but remember that this really
means
delta of the hamiltonian operator
but now we come to the key point time is
not an observable in quantum mechanics
it's a parameter this means there is no
time operator
so this should already give us a clue
that the time energy uncertainty
relation is of a rather different nature
to the usual uncertainty relations we'll
explore what this really means
in the rest of the video
the first thing we need to do is to
understand what delta t
is to do so we start with the state psi
at time t0 and write it down in the
basis of eigenstate of a
in the usual way we're again going to
represent this expansion pictorially
so we draw our axis
and this time we'll choose a rather
narrow distribution like this
the expectation value of the
distribution is centered around its
value
and its width is something like this
let's now consider the state psi at a
later time t
the expansion in the a basis now looks
like this
we can again set up the pictorial
representation
and now let's imagine that we have this
other distribution
the expectation value is here and the
width is here
we're now ready to understand the
meaning of the time interval delta t up
here
let's say delta t is the time difference
between these two situations
the numerator delta a up here is the
width of the distributions
which have chosen to be rather small and
of a similar magnitude in both cases
here
and here the denominator up here has the
time derivative of the mean
which is a measure of the difference
between the mean at the initial time
here
compared to the mean at the final time
here
so what does this mean delta t will be
very large
if it takes a long time for the
distributions to change by
more than their width and it will be
very small
if the distributions change very rapidly
compared to their width
put another way delta t measures how
fast the state of the system changes
mathematically we quantify these changes
by writing the state in terms of a basis
spanned by the eigenstate of a
particular observable in this case in
terms of a
we can of course define an analogous
delta t in terms of
any other observable of the system and
each will provide a complementary way of
understanding how
fast our state is changing
great now that we understand that delta
t is a time
scale associated with how rapidly the
state of our system changes
we can go back to the time energy
uncertainty principle
we know that in quantum mechanics time
evolution is governed by the drawing
equation
and the observable that features in this
equation is the hamiltonian
the operator associated with the total
energy of the system
and whose eigenvalue equation is this
it now makes perfect sense that the
principle up here
relates changes in time with the root
mean square deviation associated with
the energy of the system
all this principle is saying is that
there is a relation between how fast a
system can evolve in time
and how we write it down in the energy
basis
to see this explicitly let's imagine
that our system is in state psi
we can expand its state in the energy
basis to get this
as usual the expansion coefficients are
given by this expression
let's now look at a few examples to
better understand the time energy
uncertainty principle
let's first consider the case when we
have a very small uncertainty in the
energy
this means that the state of our system
can be written in terms of an expansion
that includes very few non-zero
expansion coefficients
the uncertainty principle then forces us
to have a rather large
delta t this means that the time
scale associated with changes in the
system is very long
so that the system changes very slowly
in time
this actually makes sense because we
know that the energy eigenstates
are stationary states and we'll actually
explore this in some more detail in a
moment
but before we do that let's consider the
opposite limit when we have a very large
uncertainty in the energy
this means that the state of our system
can be written in terms of an expansion
that includes many non-zero expansion
coefficients
in this case the uncertainty principle
is still obeyed even if we have a rather
small delta t
which means that the time scale
associated with changes in the system
is very short so that the system changes
very rapidly
in time so do these limits make sense
let's look at the first limit in some
more detail to convince ourselves that
this is true
let's imagine that the state of our
system at some initial time
t0 is an eigenstate of the hamiltonian
in this case we know from the video on
expectation values
that delta e vanishes
conceptually this makes sense because if
the state is an eigenstate of the
hamiltonian then there is a single term
contributing to the expansion of the
state in the energy basis so the width
of the distribution is zero
from the video on the jollinger equation
we know that the state at a later time
t is given by this expression
in turn this is equal to this global
phase factor
times the state at time t0 as global
phase factors don't matter
then this means that the physics doesn't
change with time
and these states are called stationary
states see this more concretely let's
consider the expectation value of an
observable a
at time t explicitly it's given by this
using the expression for the state up
here we can insert it
here and here and we get the bra
the operator and the ket
we can now cancel this term with this
term
and we end up with this
this is simply the expectation value of
a at the initial time t
zero this shows that for stationary
states
the expectation value of a physical
observable is the same at time t
as it is at time t zero so it doesn't
change in time
in turn this implies that the time
derivative
is equal to zero now what does all of
this mean
remembering that delta t is equal to
this
then we see that for stationary states
delta t goes to infinity
as you can probably already guess these
results are consistent with the time
energy uncertainty relation up here
if delta e is equal to 0 then we need
delta t to go to infinity to make sure
that their product obeys the uncertainty
relation
this result also makes perfect sense
from a conceptual point of view
delta t is telling us that it takes an
infinite amount of time
for the state of the system to change
which is exactly
what we expect for stationary state that
is time independent
so this example confirms our intuition
about the time energy
uncertainty relation
the time energy uncertainty principle is
rather different from the usual ones
like that between position and momentum
it gives us a relation between how fast
the quantum state of a system
evolves in time and the number of energy
eigenstates that make up that state
i hope you liked the video and as always
please subscribe